all right I'm gonna go upstairs now
what that may not have seemed weird to
you
but I literally just opened the game and
I hit continue and then suddenly the
camera zoomed out and I was back where I
was
I've never seen that in a game before
I've never seen not having a loading
screen
that was weird okay whatever hey look a
Kinesis module hey look we're back with
dead space
now I'm gonna be able to move stuff oh
use Kinesis move safe move strong
ah man I can't wait for the future when
we got this
what
who's Grumble groaning over there hang
on I gotta explore the area
he's still dark hey I did the thing I
already aimed I named and held I'm doing
the thing
doesn't seem like there's anything over
there is there anything that I would
need to go back to and then get Kinesis
for
I feel like getting Kinesis is a good
thing and then there might be something
behind me
that needed Kinesis all along
I'm a genius
no I'll probably be gone yeah I'm a
genius
I was not a genius all right so there's
gotta be well I didn't even know I was
going for that
well that was convenient
anything here want to jump out and
scream on my face
no
hmm
scan rig to unlock workstation I'm
trying
wow
very cool
but not what I'm here for I'm here for
medical I'm to look for a captain's body
Captain strong
oh hi
what
gotta hold the line
what's this hand floating
oh
I thought it was a bug that's literally
a hand with a blade on it
okay
um
now this is gonna seem really really
rude and I get that I get that but I'm
gonna stomp your corpse I'm not a
medical doctor I'm an engineer I solve
practical problems
it's not personal
foreign
rifle
wow look at that I've got a pulse rifle
what if I sh
shoot it
action okay to you
that's what I'm talking about anyway I'm
sorry ma'am
very sorry about that
just in case I don't know if a body bag
is going to help me if they all come a
stomping out towards me
I don't like the straight jacket body
bags either that's extra weird I feel
like that was added on after the fact
well
that's normal
down override lunks station lockdown
station now accessible hey that's why I
couldn't ride the tram over here
oh
okay that makes more sense yo
save quick I love saving all right so we
need to go into medical which if I
remember nothing which I do
um there's something about like doctors
in medical uh there's like medicine
and um
maybe bandages
God damn I'm strong
oh that would kill something
probably anyway maybe I
you know I'm starting to think that the
the body's moving is a feature not a bug
hello
so I know I was told to not let anything
out but you know how it is
we were attacked she ran the other way
no nothing
let it goes to slaughterhouse
a barricaded access to the morgue the
morgue yeah
but the barricade was put together in a
hurry a hydrazine tank might blow it
open just need a Detonator like maybe a
shock pad
Nicole could be through there if Isaac
the one who attacked us
I swear to God it was Chen
but
I saw him die
if they barricaded the morgue maybe it
was to keep something in
that that's a good point that that you
know
that that's a good point right there
that you made
I appreciate the wisdom that you're
mostly
I heard some rumblies over there and I
don't like them
oh I have no money
I do have crap to sell
and I have stupid suits I'm not gonna
use
see I don't even remember if I like the
pulse rifle I don't think I've ever
really used it I just the plasma cutters
just so gosh darn good all right it
wants me to go that way
but I think that way is for nerds and
I'm not a nerd I'm a cool cool guy
as has been proven many times
why why would that be required I don't
see why that's required I'm going this
way to research Wing I like research and
I'm not a nerd I'm a cool cool guy
thank you
and fall
wow oh yeah get out of my way I should
have refilled my stasis but I didn't
oh whatever what are the odds I'm gonna
need stasis again
unlikely
anybody in here
that seems relatively empty
walkie-dokey
um
oh
quarantine
hey yeah stop stop stop
[Applause]
yeah that's what I thought
take also this one
[Music]
ah damn I'm good Wham
oh
hey
that's what you get
oddly enough this is the most lighting
I've seen in a long while yo give me
your stuff come on give it to me
you better have given it to me did you
not give me anything
you serious all right
it's kind of why
I was about to say it was kind of
relaxing
I don't know why I was about to say that
but uh for some reason that seemed like
the logical thing that my brain wanted
to say what is that sound
no
hey
oh okay naked it's naked it's naked
why did I take so many shots that should
have killed you immediately
whoa oh well I should reload it
that's right
okay no no no no no no no no no yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah
I see you creeping
oh
hey cut it out
through ah yeah there you go
damn you
all right
I'm Isaac Clark and I'm getting pissed
Nicole wait is this Nicole's office oh
go
Nicole
personal log Dr Nicole Brennan with
medication and zero g therapy patient
Harris is showing improvements
continues there might be hope for the
others on ages 7. however Dr Mercer
continues to interfere
he claims Harris's delusions are
religiously significant if I have to
make a complaint I will
I'm not losing my patient over unitology
[__] not again
Dr Nicole Brennan great location
inconclusive
manual rig tracking is available
well
certain what
missions
mishans
or side missions interesting investigate
emergency room I can't reach the
emergency room until I destroy the
barricade Nicole was working in the
emergency room if I retrace her stuff so
I can find what happened to her you're
right
you're right about that
patient log okay dictation on I'll keep
your name out of the transcript thanks
it's just so hard to remember what's
real your Church Mentor talked to you
again he knows me and my girlfriend want
to leave I can feel it our last seminar
was all about Heretics however
unitologist one who leaves is an enemy
of humanity unitology is big enough to
take care of itself this is about what's
right for you just be careful the church
pulls out these tricks when they feel
threatened they have neuropsychiatrists
too even if you get out they'll try to
Dr Brennan sorry I did something happen
I had a patient who I tried and her son
tried so hard but she
I will fight for you with everything
I've got but never underestimate how
strong the church's poll can be
ye
sounds like the Church of unitology is a
bit of a
extreme organization if I do say so
oh my God okay
they are watching me poop sorry had a
formal emergency when can we
open try again I'll be here how about
before
I give
great
Peng
I don't want to know what bang is I
can't read that but one of you probably
could right somebody translate that
I can't get a good direct look at it but
that's the best you got there we go I'm
gonna translate that
Armani boss
it's remarkable
finally see what I've sought on my life
the miners this transformation
the Divine death self the guy is airing
on the side of caution his faith has
been shaken by these Necromorphs as he
calls them
how strange
when my own faith has been so richly
rewarded
whoever without kind
I must study one of these creatures for
the next best thing
Brennan's patient for example
great
good
what am I looking at
whoa baboon
then what in God's name is happening
down there precisely man
God's work
see that
these deaths at the colony
the paranoia the hallucinations
you wanted a scientific analysis
cause and effect
well it all began after they raised the
marker
are you so worried about
the marker is defined
we know this
look it'll be on board tomorrow you can
study it then put your mind at ease at
ease
people are dying how can that be the
transformation the teachings promise
we're witnessing A New Beginning parents
for unitology for Humanity of course our
faith is being tested
about to change
you know
Ah that's I was about to ask why this
was there but yeah so you were recording
it okay that makes perfect sense the vid
logs from The Colony are poor quality
but I've seen enough to confirm the
discovery to Ben the artifact appears to
be a genuine marker the first to be
found since unitology's founding we must
get it on board at the first opportunity
so I can begin a proper study I can't
even imagine the potential of such a
find the black marker offered
Revelations beyond our wildest dreams
and that was without the benefits of
current analytical technology this new
marker What secrets could it have what
wonders could it offer to humanity to
the Church of unitology without Earth
gov here to see them first this marker
could Herald the dawn of a new age and
I'm do my part to see that age come to
pass maybe this is fate in the darkest
time of my life the church and its
teachings comforted me saved me now I'm
here in the right place at the right
time the service to all Humanity to
repay those blessings
Amelia
if only you could be here now
yeah huh okay
sure I'm out of here
I didn't get what I came for I don't
think what did I come here for
oh hello ah
wow Prosthetic Center
can I get some new Birds
whoa what did I get stasis pack
schematics well those are practically
useless so why would anybody want them
[Music]
yes please thank you
oh hey almost missed you
I guess I gotta keep an eye out for that
or else I won't be able to see you okay
it's time to make a decision
what am I gonna do
what is me gonna do
I'm feeling I love the plasma cutter I
do plasma cutter is great it's fantastic
it's so good
I want to at least upgrade it a little
bit
just a little bit maybe a little
capacity why not
I'd be good that's all I need for now
I'll use the uh plasma the pulse rifle
eventually
all right where's this going
save I love saving
who goes there
oh
never okay
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
well this is disturbing for multiple
reasons
yay
yippee
oh wow
oh wow okay hey hey hey hey hey hey oh
my I don't like the eyes
uh yep
oh no
oh no okay why uh why why why why you
okay why why why why why why why why why
why
oh I don't like it
I don't like it
I don't look why
it's fine
oh Claire Claire specimen 426 is ready
for Harvest I was about to notify
Alvarez to prep the medical for leave or
for medical leave when I check the
database I saw Ensign Sable has been
moved ahead of her is that right Alvarez
has been waiting list for three months
now I thought arm transplants took
priority over acornia
here's your clerical error
douchebag one of them bought CEC stock
at the last purchase one didn't guess
which one was subtly bumped up to vital
Personnel it's not worth a headache to
push back on it trust me before you
think about filing an Ethics complaint
just remember the wise words of
Hippocrates [__] rolls downhill
them some wide wise words
oh
all right I'm gonna go upstairs now
frick
don't
don't stop why you're silent stop
[Music]
so stealthy
got a bunch of stealth babies over here
the videos want to jump out of Me Maybe
latch onto my face try to strangle me
Maybe
okay good good good is there anything
else in here
just a storage room sure I believe that
sanitary showers I mean honestly I could
use one it's kind of been a little
doesn't seem very sanitary
who's whispering
it's like bouncing around the inside of
my brain
thank you
no wow wow power oh no are you okay oh
boy
um
oh no
like this
oops
um
I'll just do is this safe I don't feel
like this safe
doors please hold doors please shock
pads uh yeah yeah yeah okay I have a
shark pad
what's your status did you find the cold
our office is empty no sign of her but I
found a shock pad I could use on the
barricade
just need a hydrazine
hurry Isaac I don't like what I'm
hearing out there
you should hear what I hear in my head
all the voices
telling me things
horrible thing
you're not hearing these voices too
hurry up I mean slow down but also hurry
slow hurry slowly hey
let's take that well that wasn't a good
idea
oh really oh my God
just working some things out
huh
really is a good stress reliever I don't
know if you've ever tried it before but
I don't know if you would ever have an
opportunity to try it before it might be
I hope you never have an opportunity to
try that but if you do it's very
therapeutic
okay what is this me talk
oh yeah the stasis back one I don't need
those stasis packs is for nerds
I don't care
I'm gonna
keep everything because once again I
don't really know when I'm on anyway no
I'm not gonna do anything
I love saving
well don't you look I can't see don't
you look chipper
hey you look so peppy I bet this is a
happy place
you uh
you okay there
you all right
uh no don't take this personally
no personalies
I think the expression is probably
nothing personal but I like no
personalies
wow that's pretty
that's very pretty
that's really pretty terrestrial longing
oh I I definitely have some terrestrial
longing if you know what I mean
oh you're scanning something oh
oh good
no personalies
well that looks like a different one
I'm gonna worry too much about it
wow looks like something
happened here
well I can't figure out what
happens if I just break
well that just makes it easier for
things to come out and I wouldn't hear
it when it did
good thing they scream
[Applause]
scream
well it seems like it goes in here
square peg round hole deal
circuit breaker huh
uh technician Diagnostics and uh
chemical lab
well it's neither of them apparently
let's see what's going on here that's a
lot of cables
this is a big ass thing
uh
uh yo you are you all right
yo oh oh you're not oh you're not oh
you're not oh you're not
you okay
now do you know about the expression no
personalies
good
glad we're on the same page
uh oh man hey a node I like nodes
level two security clearance required
more like level baloney it's ridiculous
how many nodes I got not that this
five hot diggity damn
[Music]
all right what could I do for the suit
HP
no pulse rifle
or
yep that's a good choice right there
that's the choice of a champion
me I'm the Champion All Right Moving On
so you want me to go uppies huh
well it ain't gonna happen
doors
which stores
which doors went on
doors
uh do not enter without an appointment
um
I'm entering are you gonna stop me oh
gross
patient log retrieved huh
I hear the tests on patient hairs were
inconclusive
given the reports from the colony he's
lucky to have his faculties at all well
a Divine experience would leave an
impression on anyone's mind perhaps but
I saw nothing Divine in all that blood
the suicides but this is a revelation
Terence which
look inside to translated
site can be found in Mr Harris's psyche
I'm positive
and with Captain Matthias barring any
visit
Harris and Dr Brett is patience and your
message
already
uh I don't know how long we can afford
to weigh but I know how long I can
afford oh
for the fall
um
[Music]
why why what's happening what's
happening directly behind me
are you serious
you just doing that
you goofing me
you wow there you are so come out to
silence oh shoot I missed my can you do
it again ah don't be nervous
everyone gets performance anxiety
sometimes
anything over here probably nothing
hopefully nothing something
I was over here
nothing it's a whole lot of nothing I
didn't need to come here at all
right
what do you got for me
stasis
zero g therapy why would I even want to
go there
observation room observing what oh
why why the music
observing what
all right
okay
yeah he's you got me but whatever
right whatever
the diagnoses are stacking up as fast as
I can file them sleep paralysis
hallucinations nightmare paranoia I'm
getting patience from all over the ship
no underlying causes showing up in
environmental analysis foodstuffs or
radiation levels I admit I'm at a loss
Mercer says he is kind he and kind are
working on a hypothesis so in the
meantime I'm treating the symptoms I'm
seeing some improvement with sensory
deprivation treatments in our zero g
therapy pods but the sheer number of
patients we're managing bothers me those
systems are old and they need of an
overhaul with so many pods active I
worry what might happen if there's a
serious power surge down there but
nothing else seems to help I suppose the
yards are low enough I'd rather take a
small calculated risk than have dozens
of Miners and Engineers impaired around
heavy machinery
I'm like that
yeah just stick them in the zero g tubes
let them float around for a while
there's always paying
that's the second time I've heard bang
and the first time was written on a
bathroom wall you won't tell me what
Pang is
penis enlargement and gains
I'm convinced give me
penis elongation and girthening
hang
so
why zero g therapy
what is that gonna do for the brain
because it seems like all these guys
have brain issues
whoa okay oh this is not a good thing
zero gravity ah
um man I should be worried about this oh
that's pretty though
but I won't be able to hear if
something's come after me
gosh darn it it's pretty though
anybody oxygen
hi am I
am I gonna die I might die
any goodies over there
it is pretty
gosh darn it that's pretty though
oh look at the frost that built up on me
oh you can close that oh God oh God no
God oh God
ah thank you
well that was handy
um
oh oh
sick
yes
oh yes
oh I love it
I love it
I can't believe they added this in
this is this is one of my favorite
things about Dead Space 2 uh is the fact
that it was like this zero g floating
around it just like makes it so much
more elegant this is cool it's very cool
it's dope you don't get if you're in
space if you got a game called like dead
space you better be able to
might be able to give me in space what's
down there nothing
what's over there give give thank you
there's bound to be some other goodies
floating around here
whoa I see people in the pods
okay so can you explain to me
um what it is that you're experiencing
because I'm not gonna lie this seems
like
it seems like it would be a
claustrophobics nightmare
how about that one
I don't know about that one at all all
right
which way am I going
what
ah okay
I love it
love it
very very cool oh very not cool
thank you
why
why ah
so glad everyone left their money in
their lockers
still holding this position what's
happening there I found some hydrazine
that should work on the barricade I'm
heading back there now be careful with
that hydrazine I'm not losing anyone
else
well about that
um I'm not 100 sure you can control that
and you don't really have that many
other people to lose so uh
where'd you go where'd you go I can't
see you I can't see you oh God you're in
the Darkness
oh God oh God
oh boy
okay but what if I'm take off and zoom
where you going where are you there you
go
whoa that's what you can do hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa
you suck
no no I want that
thank you
okay well Lisa didn't seem to do too
much damage when it hit me before that's
all right
I think that's the way that I need to go
back into the zero g counseling services
oh God
what the hell it shut the whole [__]
I'll check it out
okay maybe you shouldn't check it out
can I take off here holy crap I can
oh
uh uppies oh God no maybe I shouldn't
have done this huh gonna bomb
[Music]
so far so good and hey on oxygen tank
this is beautiful
that is so much blood that is so much
blood
that's too much blood
someone literally just had to explode in
that bed for someone to have created
that much blood
this even the right way to go
Oh I thought that was that looked like a
Necromorph
hey hey hey hey hey hey
those things just come after you
I don't like that they're hard to kill
it's difficult to get the right shots to
chop off their limbs but I'm pretty sure
it's got to be with the vertical slicer
otherwise
work out too good
man I must be running out of ammo if I'm
keep blasting an entire clip into them
Bing he almost got me you okay I trapped
him at a damaged Escape pod it's
gnarling like this is [__] up hurry
Isaac it's the James zero gravity
yeah I get that okay pulse rounds that's
cool
what
oh
don't like this
I don't like it
acquire steam this time oh that's not
good
chop off damn it oh my God
holy crap
okay I just need to get better at that
the damage of this thing ain't good
enough apparently
it's got to be something else for it
wham bam
foreign
[Music]
okay I'm back here finally good ready to
get back into medical with the blowing
up being the thingy in the thing
yeah yippee
yay
I like stores
great
great yeah I've got like basically
nothing left of that I do gotta
eventually
start using it because they gave me so
many pulse rounds if I don't use them
then it's all going to go to waste so I
better start
oh my gosh I'll use it I like saving
that was that was like uncomfortably
tense I didn't like that it's so dark I
can't see anything and then when they
come out they just don't die
this will work probably
oh yeah
I'll just stand right over here
Bang Bang
we have run out of body bags we need
more people here who are you writing
that note to
I don't think you're running to me
that's for sure well
you this didn't do anything die
hey Asians
this didn't do it well I barely shot it
I guess I only put like 17 bullets into
it I only put 17
no personally remember
get his root codes and the computer's
all ours
yeah I know that
find the captain's big strong body
and then what did I just do
that sounded like a shotgun
oh plasma cutter upgrade
but that was cool because I don't
know what that mean
captain
you in here
got him whisper ominously in my ear if
you're in here
give me a spectral sign from the Beyond
foreign
all right Harris is asleep after another
dose of sedative he seems literally
unable to sleep without chemical Aid
most people succumb to exhaustion after
more than 50 hours of waking regardless
of circumstances not heiress his bizarre
explanation of the events on the colony
points to the same paranoia we've seen
elsewhere PlanetSide his guilt is no
doubt he's in no doubt two security
officers were person when he took Dr
skiarello hostage and murdered nurse
Evans and Harris doesn't deny his
actions but he shows No Remorse in fact
he insisted there was no crime
specifically that Evans wasn't a nurse
when he killed her this classic
sociopathic Behavior but Harris exhibits
no other symptoms he is affable friendly
able to emphasize and offer original
opinions when questioned about Evan's
murder however he becomes withdrawn and
uncommunicative he claims the
explanation is stuck in his mind and
that talking about it mixes its up its
message he also undergoes intermittent
hallucinatory periods again similar to
those experienced by other colonists
during his long waking periods Harris
did it's writing behavior on any
available surface claiming the dreams
need to speak and that he's attempted to
make it whole again what that means I
haven't determined yet given the
complexities of his case I plan to reach
out to my colleagues for more insight
that I do
you can bet
anyway Captain hey what's going on here
Loop and transmit to all Personnel this
is senior medical officer Nicole Brennan
Medical is overwhelmed we need help
look at his wounds we can't handle so
many trauma cases and the command crew
won't tell us what's happening
[Music]
somebody else in case we left
well that's uh they're not good I
investigated it though that's nice oh
that doesn't look nice that looks less
nice oh that looks very unnice uh uh
yeah I'm gonna go with that's bad and I
don't like it
this oh it's a spike
anything need to be stabbed here
oh whoops I guess I healed
so I'm gonna go with no
all right
yeah
because of course it is okay there's got
to be a power brick around here
somewhere
uh what
am I looking at
that looks very important but I don't
know what it is
to remove the battery ensure no power is
being used on the circuit breaker okay
but what about the shower
I like showers
open the upy
what's going on in here
this ain't no shower
this ain't no shower at all
what game are you trying to play
wow
medical log Dr Nicole Brennan
so much for being paranoid
I repurposed this room to run counseling
sessions with our unitologists
interfering now it's the only place I
feel safe I recovered a limb after
yesterday's attack
genetically it's human tissue with
bizarre mutations
but it's just a sample it's not enough
to figure out a cure
there's a report from engineering
here
the engineers pulled something out of
machinery
limbs missing torso intact
okay
and for real autopsy
what was that about DNA
did you say something about DNA follow
hologram oh find autopsy location in
engineering okay well I can't promise
that I'm gonna be able to find that
no personal ease all right
does we really have to turn off the
lights is that really what we had to do
foreign
I'm gonna shotgun you
I am gonna we're baby
it is better for baby
definitely whoa oh wow all right what
are you doing
hey stop it
hey you're gonna get shotgunned oh
a day
oh that's awesome take one of ladies
all right missed that but it's okay take
one of these oh that too oh you're
floating oh it's a stasis bomb
foreign
what in the world was that
well ah damn that was nice
and that baby go
I don't know why the baby has bullets
but oh I don't want to play that again
look Nicole babe
I just can't take it anymore
uh
sure
all right so that's in there now and
that's going to power that and then
we're gonna be able to get over here
eventually I'm gonna find this goddamn
captain
no personalities
why are you twitching
oh
haunted chair I hate
I hate it ah they did too good of a job
barricading that
nothing I can do
oh
e mutations
too many more
take that
is what you get is what you get is what
you get is what you get why are you not
dead yet ow
are they getting tougher
or am I getting Dumber
[Music]
don't trust any of you at all I mean
look at that thing
look at how much blood that is
hello sorry to take all your med packs
but I don't think you need them anymore
hey wow look at ya
yeah
wow pathetic
oh
no
you have the Matthias
depression hallucinations more violence
people are dying down there I know it's
linked to the market somehow but I just
don't have enough data
maybe I'll talk
we need answers
that patient Brent Harris
might be our last hope
yeah that guy
that guy might be our last hope I've
always suspected that that's what I was
thinking all along actually hey males
security request retrieved he left me
I work in the dark with them scratching
in the walls
scratching my breath
if you will love me in with them
[__] it
I'll cut him out
hey you what okay good luck with that
oh hi
hello
how you doing oh yay
oh
uh now don't do anything drastic that
would dramatize me don't do it
[Applause]
oh hello
I agree Isaac
all right well I'm gonna try to
push that out of my mind that definitely
won't lead to years of drinking and
despair
oh well time to press on like the good
engineer that I am
I like saving
morgue this is where I should be right
well
well yep I can see that
oh thank you
wow things haven't gone uh to hell like
that that quickly
then a long while oh
oh well I'm gonna whap you with a
battery oh come on
take this and a table for a good measure
and then I'll hit you with the battery
again that's gotta hurt real bad
I feel like the battery is like such a
big thick thing that it would want you
in a heartbeat
I guess they really only die when you
caught him
who wants some nobody here all right all
right fine
you'll want some
more
all right wait a minute
I thought I saw a glowy thing which
usually is good but I don't know
[Music]
oxygen
certainly I won't need that
oh
credits and a head
good
great
stasis bomb there
it is my unfortunate duty to officially
pronounce Captain Benjamin Matthias dead
reports of the exact circumstances
surrounding his death are conflicted and
will be left for investigators to
determine once we return to Port I will
constrain my comments to the condition
of the body subject was in generally
good health for his age though cursory
blood test indicates his leukocyte count
was very low with eosinophils in
particular almost non-existent his free
flight physical exam showed no such
problems indicating rapid onset but it
does not appear to have any effect on
his death multiple contusions on the
arms and hands indicate a brief struggle
pre-mortem like contusions around the
rib cage indicate he was restrained
likely for a brief period Cause of Death
was a single prolonged trauma to the
ocular body which continued on through
the cavity wall and into the frontal
lobe causing rapid neurotrauma seizure
and death the angle of penetration into
the ocular cavity indicates the injury
was not self-inflicted examination
required the removal of the object to
confirm cause of death but it has been
preserved for the investigative team to
study I therefore have no alternative
but to record a preliminary of unnatural
death whether deliberate or accidental
is beyond my jurisdiction how very
professional and succinct
I'm trying to escape
button is sticky
hey hey it's Isaac
well you look like a captain
you don't mind if I just rip this out of
your spine do you
[Music]
okay all right and you're naked oh boy
this song that's really weird
[Music]
uh stasis
and a stomp for good measure how
are still not dead
kill the captain that was my objective
okay
okay are there more wait no I didn't
mean to do that oh god oh wait
oh wait oh
stop
oh come on
[Music]
[Applause]
just kidding
that's not what really happened that
would be that's what would have happened
if I was bad at this game here's the
real footage of me playing it
you know what to do now take some of
this
now watch this
ah you can't stand up against my skill
it's too profound for you
enough out of you I'm not even gonna let
you infect the other bodies because that
that's just how skilled I am
see I told you that's what man you
really thought something when I died
didn't you what's your status
[__] me
transmitting coats now
I shot him and a flying one turned the
captain's body into another one of those
things
same must have happened to Jen God
maybe the command computer has something
where's Daniels when you need her
head back to the security checkpoint
it's safer there at least I can upgrade
your clearance all right thanks buddy
what does that say someone please uh
translate that okay you'll never see it
you'll never see it you'll never see
you'll never see it see it you're never
gonna there it is totally straight like
that for me all right anyways yeah all
right
well this is all very lovely and I'm
extremely excited to be here but uh I'm
gonna go I now have security level one
clearance
is there any door that I'm gonna miss if
I don't go back the way I came probably
but I'm gonna go down this way because
the only one I remember was in the
emergency room can I please go in here
so I'm gonna go back to the emergency
room where I definitely remember one and
then from there I do new
oh really
but do not excuse my explode
Isaac oh here what the hell's happening
the computer says the ishimore's engines
are offline we're on a decaying orbit
toward each of seven oh God
oh God I have to get to engineering
there's no time that tram station's
offline
unless
here head back to the flight deck I'll
guide you from there if this damage
reports right there's a shortcut to
engineering
okay you know you I too like to hang up
my phone calls by ominously staring into
the camera
well the signal slowly fades
yeah is this room's real whispery hey I
missed one
better go get it
oh I can open it now because I got the
security clearance
required
okay there's probably nothing else here
let's get going
fool me once
shame me it's time
don't open the door they have come
can I have this Epic
sick oh oh all right I blew this up I
shouldn't be surprised at this at all
what are you how long were you there
were you there before
personal Aziz but don't be moving dead
bodies around because I don't remember
them I've got a Keen Eye
Maybe
least I can sell this what is that a
plasma cutter upgrade
I like that I like that
where was a workbench is the question I
have
because I want to buy something
yes
I like nodes
maybe I should have saved before I'd
have wasted all my money on that but
regrets are for nerds
I like saving all right so we're all
done in medical but I know that there
were other security doors that I could
go through
so in what I'll be back
probably I could probably come back at
some point
just do a quick scan fast forward scan
it's a quick looky-loop
ah but I gotta go all the way over there
no I'm not gonna do that oh why
huh
oh
what okay whatever let me at least
let me at least see where like
a workbench is
uh bench okay looks like a little little
Minecraft house there we go there's one
over there
probably the closest one
yeah let me at least go to that one just
gonna get to the workbench and that's
gonna be that
all right
oh good thing this place is dark
that's why I don't like the gun because
it's hard to cut things off
at least gave me the ammo that I used to
kill it
I think there was one just in here
yep anything else
anything else want to get in my way
thank you
oh
yay oh I salvaged an additional node
okay so I need wow why is that
greatly greatly
oh
that's pretty cool
that's pretty dope
um yeah I don't see why not to do that
what you're not kidding that was greatly
I'm gonna get this other damage one
all right now this thing is Big beef oh
it slices it dices it does it all that's
what I'm talking about
now that's something that can really cut
this silly thing out of here can I buy
uh plasma cutter ammo I don't recall
seeing that anywhere but um
I would like to know if I could
okay I gotta go for the arms first I
always go for legs because it keeps them
under control but I should probably just
do that only when I absolutely need uh
to keep them under control hey
he's a baby
what are you doing
gotcha
because that's gonna make him fall to
the ground and crawl but I think if you
cut off both of their arms they die no
matter what
oh you dead now
oh you're dead oh no
Oh no you're dead
oh damn that sucks for you okay I can't
but it's only six oh my God that's
unfortunate for me ah this is this is
ammo's very difficult to come by what
Easy Come his goal
all right
at least they got something I should
still use this until I can get otherwise
but man it feels bad to not be able to
use my main gun I just upgraded
get get flunked
get flunked damn it
you get Blanc then oh no can't open a
door can you
[Music]
yeah
someone on that violin's having fun
[Music]
medical has sure been a doozy
oh
so glad I'm so glad what a lovely lovely
place
lovely just darling
just incredible
so where am I going and you go back to
The Hanger cargo tram control got it
oh I don't exactly remember what I need
over there
thank you
what am I doing here
I could look in my
would be Deuce stupid
hanger Bay
another route to engineering on the
flight deck probably from the hangar Bay
interesting
yeah you might be right about that
Hammond you might be right about that
but I'm still not happy about it
do my best though I'll do my best
if my best ain't good enough I'll be
dead so it's not really a problem
why do you gotta make every elevator
ride spooky
why you gotta make the voices and music
go all over my head like that how do you
make things sound uppies
oh
thanks for showing me this again I
appreciate it I guess great
why did I need to see that again
why did you find that necessary is there
any other ah was there any other
um like level one security things down
that first way that you run I doubt it
nah nah not worth it let's just go for
it
less no it's got to be over here
Isaac
it says there's a broken cargo lift just
beyond the hangar doors I'll open them
now
entering the zero gravity okay but uh
I don't have any Oxygen
you'll need thrusters to reach it but
that lift shaft should take you straight
down to engineering
oh
all right looks like we're
done with chapter two
which means that we're done with this
episode thank you everybody so much for
joining me on this journey we'll be back
real soon with even more dead space
Don't You Worry About a Thing
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye